hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory as
you may recall I recently released a
video on the worst fan theories that I
came across in 2022 well in today's
video we're going to be taking a look at
the opposite end of the spectrum
discussing the best Harry Potter
theories to have surfaced or been
discussed within the last year from good
to absolutely amazing I'll be taking you
through these theories some of which
were indeed proven with the newest
Fantastic Beasts the secrets of
Dumbledore film released earlier in 2022
others I either found fascinating or
simply brilliant 10. Hermione and Ron
were character foils for Lily and James
Potter to get things started the first
fan theory that I'd like to discuss is
the idea that Hermione and Ron were
character foils for Lily and James
Potter what exactly does this mean well
I'm so glad you asked let's start with
the backgrounds of Harry's parents Lily
and Potter Lily was a muggle born where
true from what we know about her
relationship but Severus Snape was
compassionate and kind she was also
rather Brave and intelligent as
supported by her replacement in
Gryffindor House at Hogwarts not to say
anything of how she sacrificed her own
life in her effort to protect her infant
son from Lord Voldemort's killing curse
James on the other hand was a pure blood
wizard descended from a long line of
magical ancestors he was known to be
somewhat hot tempered and not always the
kindest in his youth again these are
things we've picked up from how he
interacted with or rather how he bullied
Severus Snape but James was also
incredibly Brave and loyal to his
friends the Marauders so what's the
theory well it doesn't take much to see
the glaring similarities between Lily
and Hermione Granger the muggleborn
extremely compassionate remember her
Society for the promotion of elfish
welfare and fiercely intelligent wedge
and best friend to Harry there are also
many similarities between James and Ron
as you may know Mr Weasley also came
from a long line of pure Bloods lost his
temper quite easily and was one of the
most loyal people Harry had ever met are
these similarities merely coincidences
perhaps but I think it's more likely
that JK Rowling saw them as character
Falls for Harry's parents and used them
to guide Harry through his years at
Hogwarts in ways that his late mum and
dad were never able to do 9. Abba forth
and his thing for goats next up Abba
forth and his thing for goats now before
the release of Fantastic Beasts the
secrets of Dumbledore it had been
mentioned that aberforth albus's much
gruffa younger brother had been charged
with performing inappropriate charms on
goads theories and speculations ran
rampant on what exactly this meant how
inappropriate were these charms does
that mean what we think it means
couldn't be could it well it has in fact
been confirmed by JK Rowling that these
inappropriate charms which got
amberforth arrested were exactly what we
thought they were what's more
aberforth's odd obsession with the
creatures is further supported by what
we see of him in the secrets of
Dumbledore surely you noticed his Keen
interest in the chillin
8. Snape's opening lines to Harry are a
coded statement about Lily Potter
there's been some debate back and forth
between fans for years on this topic so
it's hardly a new Theory but it's just
so bloody brilliant that I had to at
least acknowledge it here there was a
fan Tom Hiddles whose theory blew up in
many Publications back in 2016. around
the same time as the death of Alan
Rickman the actor who famously played
Severus Snape in the Harry Potter films
Tom hiddle's theory is as follows the
first thing Snape asked Harry is Potter
what would I get if I added powdered
root of asphidel to an infusion of
wormwood according to Victorian flower
language asphidel is a type of lily
meaning my regrets follow you to the
grave and wormwood means absence and
also typically symbolized bitter sorrow
if you combine that it meant I bitterly
regret Lily's death however I've also
come across the following argument that
challenges the interpretation of Snape's
first words to Harry Reddit user by the
name of Ted The Geek atheos claims
aspidel is a type of Lily which was
associated with death and graves in
ancient Greece wormwood is also called
Artemisia absintheum which was commonly
burned as a protective offering by the
Greeks to their gods what he was saying
was on Lily's grave I promised to
protect you I go into this theory in
more depth in my video on the topic of
five Severus Snape theories good and bad
I recommend you check it out if you'd
like to learn more 7. Azkaban was a way
to contain prisoners and the Dementors
after the introduction of Dementors in
the Prisoner of Azkaban many fans
ruminated on the idea that the magical
jailhouse was as much a prison for the
Dementors as it was for the criminals
being held there Dementors were meant to
be asked band guards however it seemed
like the perfect setup to keep these
soul-sucking beings from breaking havoc
on the Wizarding World
well JK Rowling has indeed confirmed
this Theory as being true 6. the
Dementors were more interested in Harry
than other Wizards on the topic of
Dementors did it ever seem strange to
you that these creepy ghoul-like
creatures appeared to be a heck of a lot
more interested in Harry Potter than any
other witch or wizard well the theory
here is that that's because they were
more interested in him as a horcrux
Harry actually had more than just his
One Soul inside his body he had his soul
plus a piece of voldemorts of course
this would mean that any dementor who
got to suck out his soul would get more
than it bargained for and it's likely
that the mentors could sense this 5.
Ariana Dumbledore was an obscurial as
you may remember earlier in 2022 I
speculated that Ariana Dumbledore
albus's ill-fated sister was an
obscurial in my video who killed
Dumbledore's sister Ariana what happened
to her this Theory cropped up as a
result of what we had come to learn
about Credence bare bone the wizard
turned obscurial in the Fantastic Beast
series it was extremely exciting to have
this Theory confirmed in the secrets of
Dumbledore film which came out just a
short while later 4. Dumbledore had more
than one hidden agenda it's well known
that Dumbledore was a wizard of many
Secrets One in particular that nobody
was very happy to learn about was that
Albus had been hiding his agenda of
raising Harry up all those years only to
have him confront Voldemort and die even
Snape was Furious but the real question
is what else was he hiding were there
other plots and strategies that he was
secretly masterminding behind the scenes
what else was Albus Dumbledore doing in
the shadows in the name of the greater
good well there are a couple theories
that touch on this the first one is
Dumbledore knew that a life with the
dursleys might make Harry become an
obscurial of course because albus's
sister Ariana had been one he would have
known all too well that this would have
been the possibility the theory goes
that he took the risk figuring that if
it were to occur at the very least Harry
would have been able to take on
Voldemort with more intensity of power
there's also the idea that Dumbledore
had secretly put a protective spell on
Hogwarts so none of the students would
die while he was Headmaster so many
perilous dangers came to Hogwarts during
the series and yet Dumbledore never
seemed particularly worried what's more
none of the students that I can think of
actually died while he was Headmaster
the final Theory within this theory is
that Dumbledore intended for Harry to
fail in his occlimency lessons with
Snape in order to provoke Voldemort into
misguided action he was obviously quite
aware of the tension and history between
Severus and Harry which makes it hard
for me to believe that he thought
putting these two together for these
lessons was a sensible idea but the
notion that he may have done this on
purpose fits much better into what we
know about Dumbledore and his
willingness to put Harry and others In
Harm's Way in the name of the greater
good 3. Credence is a Dumbledore and a
prince the heritage of Queen's bare bone
has been a topic of discussion since the
release of the first fantastic Beast
movie
with the answer of who his father was
released in the latest film the question
of his mother's identity Still Remains a
mystery well it is my belief that
Credence could be a relation of none
other than Severus Snape for he could
have been Eileen Prince Snape's mothers
father's cousin or put more plainly a
secret son of one of Eileen's
grandfather's sisters I explored this
theory in more depth in my video who is
credence's Mother you should definitely
check it out if you'd like to learn more
2. why Voldemort looks only half human
this is one of the more gruesome
theories on the list but it's one that
makes complete sense to me the theory
goes at Voldemort had to give up pieces
of his own body in order to bind his
soul to each physical horcrux as he
created more horcruxes and gave up more
pieces of his body his looks
deteriorated as you may recall upon his
rebirth he had no-nos red slits for eyes
and pale gray skin who knows what else
he was missing 1. Harry was the master
of death our final theory of today and
my top pick for the best theory of the
list is that Harry was the unnamed
master of death many fans were
completely outraged when Harry simply
snapped the Elder Wand in half in the
final movie This was meant to be the
greatest weapon in the Wizarding World
he shouldn't have been able to just
break it with his hands like that but
Harry had Mastery of the Elder Wand and
the invisibility cloak and the
resurrection Stone the three items named
in the Fable the three brothers that
when held by one which or wizard would
make that person the master of death
it's actually pretty straightforward if
you think about it an interesting note
to make from this Revelation is the idea
that Harry may have only been able to
return to the land of the living after
Voldemort hit him with the killing curse
because he was the master of death this
challenges the idea that he was able to
return because Voldemort's curse only
killed the horcrux inside him which I
always took issue with and with that
we've come to the end of another video
what did you think did I miss any
theories from the past year that you
thought were better please share your
thoughts in the comments below and as
always if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to like it and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live
[Music]